50 million Europeans can't afford to
keep warm in winter or cool in summer a
scandal said one MEP who at this week's
mini cannery advanced a raft of
proposals to help them and for all
consumers stable affordable energy
people are actually dying because
they're frightened of the bills this
cannot be right in 2016 she also
proposed widely supported ideas for
local collaboration in the generation of
renewables the empowerment of individual
consumers may be to work on the
co-operative model so they can supply
their own energy the dutch king
willem-alexander addressed Parliament on
Wednesday and called for strong
cooperation in creating jobs and
tackling the refugee crisis climate
change and energy also lauded decades of
peace in Europe Aerosmith's of social
events australia since the shoe mont
blanc can anchor this last meals hope on
unrelated subtlest
Amy peas debated proposals to advance
the still unfinished digital single
market that boost ecommerce in
particular consumers digital rights and
also blocking geo-blocking the practice
which limits access to Internet services
in different countries myself ng ganun
bad news is this year of mere
transparency in iron coffin internet hub
for the first time Parliament debated
the opportunities and risks and virtual
currencies like Bitcoin recommending the
establishment of a task force to monitor
and if necessary regulate developments
in the field the sakharov prize network
conference took place at the start of
the week with past Sakharov Prize
laureates addressing a range of human
rights questions including defending the
defenders religious diversity and human
rights in the digital age among the
guests the wife of the Saudi rife badali
jailed for his free-thinking blogs mr.
near on isla de Gallina i thought the
morn woodson lohan and including sorry
one from saudi arabians a pelear handed
avi all the year the vibe of a forged
eagle heights velocity